The nineteenth century was the time of great
inventors and great inventions.
Along the way, Thomas Edison became one of
the best-known and most admired inventors
in history.
Nikola Tesla is arguably less well-known.
Only recently has he attracted renewed attention
thanks in part to the electric car company
that bears his name.
In 1884, when Tesla was 28 years old, he sailed
for New York with only four cents in his pocket.
His money and some of his luggage were stolen
on the way over.
Like other immigrants, Tesla came to America
for work.
He had been hired as an engineer at Edison
Machine Works in Manhattan.
Tesla admired Edison, recalling: "One of the
great events in my life was my first meeting
with Edison.
This wonderful man, who had received no scientific
training, yet had accomplished so much, filled
me with amazement.”
Edison was also impressed with the young engineer,
remarking to an assistant: “...this is a
damn good man!”
It didn’t take long, however, for things
to turn sour as the two men disagreed over
how electricity should be delivered to the
masses.
In 1879, Edison created the first practical
incandescent lightbulb and then built a system
to carry electricity so people could use his
new invention.
He opened up his first power plant in New
York in 1882 supported by his Direct Current
electrical system known as DC.
A network of underground cables would carry
electricity from a generator to homes and
businesses.
But his DC generators kept failing.
So he hired the young Serbian engineer to
improve them.
Tesla saw the weaknesses of direct current
which travels through a power line in one
direction at a constant voltage.
But there’s a critical flaw: it can only
go up to a mile before losing power.
Tesla felt he had come up with a better solution:
alternating current.
AC periodically changes direction and can
also vary its voltage.
The crucial advantage is that it can travel
hundreds of miles without losing power.
Yet when Tesla tried to convince Edison of
the advantages of AC, his boss wasn’t having
any of it.
Edison didn’t want to lose the royalties
he earned from his DC patents.
Tesla claimed Edison promised him $50,000
if he could improve on his DC generators and
when he did, Edison refused to pay up and
is said to have responded: “Tesla, you don’t
understand our American humor”.
So Tesla quit after just a few months on the
job, writing in his diary:
“Good by to the Edison Machine Works”.
Tesla set out on his own hoping to find investors
interested in his concept for an AC motor
that he had patented.
Yet he struggled.
Alternating current was a totally new technology.
Not something anyone had ever seen before.
He even briefly had to resort to digging ditches
just to survive.
But there was one person who took a chance
on him.
Entrepreneur George Westinghouse saw the potential
of AC.
He believed AC was THE missing link in long-distance
power transmission.
So he purchased Tesla’s AC patents for $60,000
and offered Tesla stock and royalties of $2.50
for each horsepower of electricity sold.
All of this is worth millions today.
Edison tried to do everything he could to
discredit Tesla’s AC system so that DC would
be the preferred choice to power homes.
He found an ally in J.P. Morgan, at the time
the most powerful banker in America.
This would lead to the birth of General Electric.
The battle against Tesla and Westinghouse
is now known as the War of the Currents.
And in many ways, it was a propaganda war
launched by Edison to try to convince the
public that AC was dangerous.
He zeroed in on the fact that alternating
current operated at much higher voltages than
direct current.
When the state of New York commissioned an
electricity salesman named Harold Brown to
build the electric chair, Edison paid him
behind the scenes to use his rival’s AC
generators secured through a second-hand dealer.
Brown also used AC to electrocute dogs at
Edison’s laboratory in New Jersey, which
Edison recalled in articles he published,
writing: “I have myself seen a large healthy
dog killed instantly by the alternating current.”
Other animals were not immune to his schemes.
Edison’s company electrocuted a circus elephant
named Topsy using AC and produced a film about
it.
His anti-AC crusade may or may not have also
come from a genuine concern about safety.
He wrote a letter warning the president of
his electric light company of the danger of
AC, declaring: "Just as certain as death,
Westinghouse will kill a customer within six
months after he puts in a system of any size."
Sure enough, there were several accidental
deaths due to the high voltages of AC in the
late 1880s in New York and several other cities.
In one incident, telegraph lineman John Feeks’
body was left hanging in tangled wires in
front of a horrified crowd.
His death led to laws to move AC lines underground
in New York City.
Tesla felt that the only way to show AC was
safe was to demonstrate it on himself.
In a dramatic display at Columbia University,
he grasped a brass ball in each hand and touched
the terminals of a high-voltage, high-frequency
transformer now known as a Tesla coil.
250,000 volts raced across the surface of
his body.
A newspaper reported that he was surrounded
by “...tongues of electric flame.”
In 1893, Tesla and Westinghouse scored a big
win when they beat out Edison to light up
the Chicago World Fair using alternating current.
The first all-electric fair in history.
Three years later, Tesla lit up the city of
Buffalo using AC motors powered by the waters
of Niagara Falls.
This was Tesla’s childhood dream.
As a kid, he saw an image of the Falls and
told his uncle that one day, he’d go to
America and capture the energy of Niagara.
The first hydroelectric power plant at Niagara
Falls would mark the beginning of the electrification
of the world.
When he gave a speech at the opening ceremony,
Tesla said: “It is a monument worthy of
our scientific age...”
“It signifies the subjugation of natural
forces to the service of man, the discontinuance
of barbarous methods, the relieving of millions
from want and suffering."
Today, almost every home in the world is powered
by AC whereas DC powers smaller items, anything
that uses batteries: from your electric toothbrush
to the clock on the wall.
Despite the success of AC, Tesla never went
on to the fame and fortune that Edison enjoyed.
Because Edison was not only an inventor.
He was a businessman, honing his craft at
the age of 13 when he started selling candy,
newspapers, and vegetables on trains and turned
an amazing profit of $50 a week in his day
- about $1,600 today.
Edison would likely have made a different
choice when confronted with the challenging
situation that Tesla faced next.
The war of the currents took a financial toll
on Westinghouse whose company racked up millions
of dollars in debt.
When Westinghouse begged Tesla to lower his
royalty rate in order to save the company,
Tesla did more than that.
He tore up his contract - relinquishing his
royalties altogether.
It’s estimated that Tesla willingly walked
away from $12 million in royalties in his
day which today would be worth well over $300
million.
Those royalties were so valuable they would
have accrued over time to turn Tesla into
the world’s first billionaire.
In return, Westinghouse paid him a lump sum
of $216,000 for the right to use his AC patents
forever which is roughly $5 million today.
Tesla’s decision would hurt him dearly because
he ended up short of cash to fund his other
grand ideas.
He had discovered that his powerful coil made
it possible to send and receive radio signals.
But in 1895, a fire broke out at the building
housing his New York lab as he was about to
transmit a signal 50 miles to West Point,
New York.
The blaze destroyed everything: his models,
designs, notes, and tools.
The timing was terrible because Italian inventor
Guglielmo Marconi was also developing radio
in England, sending Morse-code-based signals.
Tesla still managed to beat Marconi to the
punch by filing American patents for the radio
first, in 1897.
When Marconi tried to do the same a few years
later, the U.S. Patent Office turned him down
because his were too similar to Tesla’s.
Repeated applications were rejected.
But Marconi did attract the attention of none
other than Edison who invested in him and
became a consulting engineer at Marconi’s
company.
The Italian’s greatest achievement came
in 1901 when he received the first radio signal
sent across the Atlantic from a transmitter
in southwest England to St John’s Newfoundland
in Eastern Canada.
This won Marconi international fame.
And he had to use Tesla’s patents to achieve
it.
But Tesla didn’t mind.
When one of his engineers said: "Looks as
if Marconi got the jump on you."
Tesla replied: "Marconi is a good fellow.
Let him continue.
He is using seventeen of my patents.”
Unfortunately, no patent is truly safe.
In 1904, the Patent Office decided inexplicably
to rewrite history by awarding Marconi a patent
for the invention of the radio, reversing
its earlier decisions.
It gave no reason.
But it didn’t hurt that Marconi had the
financial backing of Edison and other influential
people.
In 1909, Marconi won the Nobel Prize in physics
for the invention of the radio.
Tesla was furious.
And sued the Marconi Company for infringement.
The radio incident led Tesla to lose business
opportunities.
For example, Tesla had a grand vision for
wireless electricity.
His proposal initially caught the attention
of J.P. Morgan who put up $150,000 to build
a giant transmission tower in 1901.
Tesla believed the 187-foot, 57-meter tall
Wardenclyffe Tower in Long Island, New York
was the start of a system that could deliver
electricity without wires around the globe.
And anyone with the right equipment could
tap into it.
He imagined a scenario where “...it will
be possible for a businessman in New York
to dictate instructions, and have them instantly
appear in type at his office in London or
elsewhere.”
It was incredibly prescient to envision telecommunications
infrastructure much like today’s Internet
more than a century ago.
But Tesla’s vision would never bear fruit.
Electricity can indeed be transmitted through
the air but it’s impractical because of
the amount of power needed to make it happen.
So, Tesla appealed to Morgan for more money.
It was all for naught.
Morgan was throwing money in the other direction
toward Marconi.
Wardenclyffe Tower was never completed and
would eventually be demolished, along with
Tesla’s vision.
Tesla was devastated and had a breakdown,
lamenting: ”It is not a dream.
It is a simple feat of scientific electrical
engineering, only expensive—blind, faint-hearted,
doubting world!”
Tesla began to withdraw from that world.
He showed signs of obsessive-compulsive disorder
which compelled him to do things in threes,
including living in a hotel room that was
divisible by the number three.
He spent the last decade of his life living
out of a hotel paid for by the Westinghouse
Corporation which kept him on as a consultant.
He was broke.
And befriended pigeons.
Edison on the other hand continued to reap
immense rewards.
Businesses and partnerships filled his life.
By the time he died in 1931, he patented a
record 1,093 inventions.
There was the lightbulb, of course, but also
the motion picture camera, and the early record
player called a phonograph.
Today - he is considered one of the world’s
greatest inventors.
It was only after Tesla’s death that he
got a modicum of justice for all that he had
lost.
When Tesla sued Marconi, the case dragged
on in court for years.
Six months after his passing in 1943, the
U.S. Supreme Court ruled Marconi’s radio
patents were invalid and awarded the patents
for the radio to Tesla.
But it had a selfish reason for doing so.
Marconi’s company had sued the U.S. government
for patent infringement during World War I.
So to avoid the lawsuit altogether, the Supreme
Court deemed Tesla the inventor of the radio.
Today, at the site where Tesla’s Wardenclyffe
Tower once stood, is a science museum dedicated
to the man whose dreams were not to be.
The Tesla Science Center was made possible
thanks to the financial support of thousands
of Tesla fans, including Tesla CEO Elon Musk.
Tesla’s prediction of transmitting data
without wires came true in the early nineties.
The internet has changed our lives yet at
the same time, it’s important to stay protected
online.
If you've been following me for a while, you
know that I only endorse products that I personally
use which is why I'm really excited this video
is sponsored by Private Internet Access.
Private Internet Access hides my IP address
so that my Internet Service Provider can’t
see the websites I visit.
Changing your IP address is a great way to
convince anyone that you’re in a different
location than where you currently are.
Besides the security aspect, a VPN is super
handy to access content on YouTube or Netflix
that’s otherwise not available in your region.
What I really like about Private Internet
Access is that they don’t log any data.
This means they’ll have no idea when I’m
using the VPN, for how long, or even what
sites I’ve been visiting.
If you go to my link to support my channel,
you’ll get an 83% discount so that the price
of complete digital privacy is just $2.08
a month + you’ll get 2 extra months for
free with a 30-day money-back guarantee.
You can use the same subscription to protect
up to 10 devices at the same time on any platform.
Simply head to www.privateinternetaccess.com/newsthink
to get the promotion.
The link is in my description.
I hope you enjoyed the video and if you did,
don’t forget to give it a like.
And if there’s a story idea you’d like
to see, feel free to leave a comment below.
Thanks so much for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.